today on the matt walsh show mike pence
dominates in the vice presidential
debate last night the media is so
desperate to distract from pence's
brilliant performance that they're now
accusing him of sexism for debating a
woman
at a debate against a woman also five
headlines including
more rioting and looting for perhaps the
most absurd reason yet and in our daily
cancellation i will cancel
celebrities who got naked in order to
encourage people to vote but i'm not
only canceling them i'll also be
cancelling all
get out the vote drives they're all
cancelled they all should be abolished
and i'll explain why but first let's
talk about expressvpn you know
the internet is a place where people
feel safe sharing their views
and they should you know i certainly
share my views all the time here but the
problem is that you can end up getting
targeted for your beliefs
you know what big tech and big
government have in common actually a lot
but uh
here's one they both want to silence any
dissenting voices
into submission i mean let's say you're
a proud gun owner
you want to talk on social media about
the right to bear arms well chances are
your post will be flagged by a content
moderator and you might end up on some
kind of
government watch list you know you never
know to fight back against having your
voice censored by both big tech and big
government i recommend expressvpn when i
use expressvpn
you know they can't see my my ip address
at all
my identity is is anonymous
it's made that way by secure vpn server
plus expressvpn encrypts 100 of my
internet
internet data for protection from
hackers and eavesdroppers expressvpn is
by far
the best vpn i've tried it's a vpn rated
number one by cnet wired
countless other tech publications this
is just the smart move it's the right
thing to do it's what
i do what i do what you should do
protect yourself give yourself some
privacy
stop letting big tech and big government
censor and track you defend your rights
protect yourself at walsh expressvpn.com
expressvpn.comvpn.comwalsh
to get three months free visit
expressvpn.comwalsh
to learn more okay let's talk about the
debate now and as i do so from this
ritzy hotel room because i am
here in grove city pennsylvania waiting
to speak at grove city college at seven
o'clock tonight
if you're in the area come on out i'm
excited to be speaking to people live in
person for the first time in months so
that'll be great grove city college
tonight
hope to see you there uh now as for the
debate um it was not a surprise
you know to see vice president mike
pence win the debate
against senator camallo harris a woman
who threatens at times to make hillary
clinton appear
genuine and likable by comparison but it
was perhaps unexpected to see pence
in his polite understated
midwestern way dominate and humiliate
harris to such an extent
to such an extent that the mainstream
media was forced to make headlines
out of the fly that landed on pence's
head for two minutes
anything to distract from the substance
of his performance anything to avoid the
real headline which is mike pence wins
big
in fact the left has been so desperate
in the aftermath of the debate
that an msnbc guest went into a lengthy
discourse
on the fly eventually concluding that
the fly was an omen
it's the mark of the devil listen
if this was a normal debate his behavior
would have been scored very very poorly
would have been on the higher end
of weird behavior and not for nothing i
mean i don't think it's ever a good sign
when a fly lands on your
head for two minutes you know that's a
that's a sign all through history of sin
and historically biblically uh maybe
you wouldn't normally say this after uh
you wouldn't it's only safe to say this
sorry after midnight but
you know the a fly he who commands the
fly has always been seen historically
the mark of the devil
now as a journalist now i have to ask
for the record are you joking because uh
the fly could have landed on anyone yes
but it didn't it landed on mike pence
and it and it says something
i don't think karmic about the status of
the campaign as it implodes
now if we really want to play this game
with the fly then we could talk about
the time that obama nearly had a fly pry
its way into his mouth
and you know as this photographic
evidence confirms but
let's not talk about the flight the fly
was not the only headline to come out of
the debate
according to our diligent journalist
class mike pence also had
one eye that was a little red this
provided fodder for extensive commentary
from forbes buzzfeed los angeles times
and other esteemed publications also
mike pence's wife karen
appeared on stage to congratulate her
husband after the debate and was not
wearing a mask
which provoked indictments from the
huffington post
newsweek new york times imagine their
shock and horror should they learn that
karen pence
also presumably doesn't wear a mask when
she sleeps in the same bed as her
husband or
sits on the the sofa next to him to
watch tv
or spends much of her life in close
proximity to him
but the big news even bigger than the
flies and the pink eye
you can believe it is that vice
president mike pence
was a sexist for committing the
unthinkable sin
of debating a woman during a debate
against a woman right on cue nearly as
nearly as soon as the broadcast
concluded dan rather and others in the
news media
were accusing pence of mansplaining
george stephanopoulos at abc
also latched on to this mansplaining
talking point here's what he said
sarah fagan let me bring that to you
because obviously mike pence
his former television commentator does
have a very calm demeanor
but i think a lot of people were
noticing some mansplaining going on
tonight
i don't know i didn't see it that way
george it didn't come across to me
now notice how he ironically tries to
explain about mansplaining to a woman
who disagrees with him which is funny
also major garrett at cbs
gushed with pride exclaiming that harris
was an inspiration for women everywhere
when she asserted herself against the
rude man who kept arguing with her
almost as if they were taking part in an
event where the whole point is to argue
with each other
here's what he said i think there was
something very stylistically
important and just because it's
stylistic doesn't mean it doesn't have
weight i think this will
and back me up on this caitlyn and
elaine because i'm sure you heard it as
well
when she was being interrupted senator
harris did not look at the vice
president and say
don't interrupt me what did she say i'm
speaking now
i think that is an important stylistic
difference she's not giving
the vice president an order stop
interrupting me she is asserting i am
speaking now
and i think many american women heard
that and said i know what that feels
like
i know what that is in that moment
i'm speaking and i should be allowed to
speak
and there were more and nbc presidential
historian michael uh beschloss
noted that pence was interrupting not
just one woman but two
both his female opponent and the female
moderator
this this he says shows a lack of
respect over on cnn sc cup
was apoplectic ranting about how pence's
alleged
sexism and mansplaining was quote
infuriating
it made her skin crawl here's what she
said let me
let me just start by saying i i know
mike pence i've met mike pence i've
interviewed mike pence and at one time i
found him very impressive
tonight he made my skin crawl
uh and i think showed that you can uh
be insulting without using insults um
you know the the constant interruptions
the mansplaining
the condescending uh to both of the
women
uh on that stage tonight and and the not
answering questions the gaslighting
i found infuriating and predictably uh
congresswoman
alexandra queza cortez got in on the
identity politics action
okay she can't let this go away without
without having her say
she said that pence daring to ask
questions to harris
was misogynistic and quote exemplary of
the gender
dynamics so many women have to deal with
at work
feminist writer jill of filopovich
claimed bizarrely that it was
condescending and sexist
for pence to call kamela by her name
okay jill many publications such as the
hill extolled harris's courage in the
face of these horrific attacks
celebrated her inspirational you know
girl power performance
on and on and on now this is all
nonsense of course the candidates spoke
for the same amount of time
or harris actually had more speaking
time depending on which tally you
believe but by no one's count
did pence hog the stage and take
significantly more than his fair share
of the speaking time
he did argue with harris and attempt to
explain his point of view
but that again is the entire point of a
debate
pence approached this encounter like he
did with
tim kaine in 2016. and speaking of 2016
donald trump was frequently accused of
sexism for interrupting and
and and talking over hillary clinton yet
trump did
far more of that sort of thing against
joe biden last week
it seems these men are just debating
how they debate regardless of the gender
of their opponent indeed
it can be said in general that any woman
who is interrupted and talked over by
any man
is most likely being treated exactly as
that man treats
other men it's also how that woman
likely treats
other men and how she treats other women
it is to put it simply
just people being people it is equality
and that's supposed to be what feminists
are fighting for
but as we've learned time and again
feminists actually want special
treatment even while clamoring for equal
treatment
in a strange way they have become our
culture's great defenders of chivalry
yet they pretend to hate chivalry and
advocate for a version of it
while claiming to want the opposite of
it and that's how we end up with a
spectacle like last night they tell us
that women are strong and tough and
can hang in there against any man and
then proceed to wilt like delicate
flowers when a woman was
subjected to mild pushback from one of
the least aggressive
most polite men in politics it is an
absurd and transparent tactic
but it's all they have i can only hope
that most americans are
too smart to fall for it let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
speaking of debates it uh if we must
continue speaking of debates
the daily wire reports the second
presidential debate between president
donald trump and democratic nominee joe
biden will take place
virtually with both candidates in
separate locations the commission on
presidential debates announced on
thursday
the commission announced the new form
after trump tested positive chronovirus
last
week trump responded to the news minutes
later asserting he
would not do a virtual debate um
according to a statement from the
commission the second presidential
debate will take the form of a town
meeting in which the candidates would
participate from separate remote
locations the town meeting participants
and the moderator steve scully
will be located at the adrian arsht
center for the performing arts
the white house pool will provide
coverage of the second presidential
debate okay
but trump says uh on fox business he was
he was asked about it and he said i'm
not gonna do a virtual debate
i you know i think this is a mistake
personally i'm probably gonna be in the
minority
among conservatives i don't know i'm not
really sure if i will be or not but i
think trump needs to do the debate
he's down in the polls uh the last
debate didn't go very well for him
you know he he has more to gain from
another debate than
than biden does um
so this the strategy of not doing it i
don't
i don't really see you know you know i
and this has been
my point i think it's a little bit of a
little bit of maybe tough love tough
talk
for uh some conservatives and some trump
supporters
who are whistling past the graveyard a
little bit
and we see all these polls coming out
and almost all of them look bad for
trump
to varying degrees um
and but what we hear of course is that
well you know you can't trust the polls
they were wrong in 2016.
2016. remember 2016. this is how it was
in 2016. everybody said trump would get
killed in 2016. he didn't 2016 2016.
yeah i know that was 2016 though it's
not 2020.
you're never going to win a campaign by
pretending that it's four years ago
especially when so much has happened in
the
in the uh intervening years and
especially when there are so
there are a lot of obvious differences
here number one he's not running against
hillary clinton anymore that was a big
advantage
he had being that she still is the least
likeable person on planet earth she was
also under investigation by the fbi at
the time
so i mean he he he couldn't have asked
for a better opponent
so he doesn't have that no there are a
lot of weaknesses to joe biden but he's
not
hillary clinton he's he's not just this
viscerally
detestable guy you might not like him i
don't like him
but i'm talking about how he's perceived
in the public it's not like hillary
clinton
uh so he doesn't have that going for him
he's not he's not a novelty
act anymore he's the incumbent and then
you add in
you know the economy coronavirus riots
everything some of that cuts for him
some of it against him
but it's just it's the point is it's an
entirely different situation and so if
you're if you're telling yourself ah
it'll be fine because remember 2016.
i think we're making a big mistake and
remember this is the mistake
that a lot of hillary clinton supporters
made
in 2016 it's because they were so
confident now i'm going to have a fly
problem
it's going to be flying up but this is
the good thing is if i have a fly on my
head you won't be able to see it because
i've got
that's pence's problem you had white
hair so you could see the fly anyway
um but hillary clinton supporters
were so confident that i think many of
them didn't show up because they figured
that they were going to win and
um i think that's that's a foolhardy
confidence you don't want to have
so uh trump needs to really try
to win if he doesn't try he's not going
to and i think that includes doing the
debate now
that said
objecting to a virtual debate i think
doesn't make a lot of sense
but i do think there are other reasons
other good reasons to object
to a debate and one thing that trump
could do is
take issue with the moderator i mean i
think that the republicans in general
forget about format virtual or not when
it comes to the moderators
republicans in general should be putting
their foot down and saying we are not
going to do any more debates
period at all until you give us a
moderator
who is not an unofficial member of my
opponent's campaign
it's not an unreasonable demand the
moderator last night i thought was even
worse than chris wells
absolute embarrassment a lot of examples
of bias the most biased thing we got
though
from the moderator last night was when
she was talking about the brianna taylor
case i don't know if you picked up on
this she referred to the police officers
breaking in to briana taylor's apartment
they were serving a legal warrant and
she categorized that as a break-in just
an absurdly
biased framing and in false framing for
the question but that's what you get
from these moderators okay
number two well it's uh groundhog's day
all over again more rioting this time in
wauwatosa a city in wisconsin here's
just one short clip of the rioting watch
this
[Music]
uh
the reason for the riot is the da's
decision not to charge the officer with
a crime in the shooting of alvin cole
cole 17 year old black male was shot by
officer joseph mensah at a shopping mall
the d.a says that cole was armed with a
stolen pistol
he had flashed it at somebody during an
argument and then he pulled the gun
on the cops he actually fired the gun he
hit himself apparently in the process
but
he pulled a gun and fired it and that's
when he got shot
the officer who shot him by the way is
black
okay he's a black man but
this somehow so you a black police
officer
uh shooting an armed
person who pulled a gun on him that
somehow is racist
police brutality a black police officer
shooting a guy who points a gun at him
is a racist police brutality well sure
why not because
none of these words have any meaning
anymore they have just no meaning you
can use them however you like
the words like racist police brutality
they should have meaning
in reality they have meaning but the way
they're used there's no meaning you just
throw them out it doesn't matter if it
applies or not
um i'll have more to say about this case
probably tomorrow so we'll we'll get
back to it
number three from reuters says netflix
incorporated is facing a criminal charge
in a texas county for promoting
lewd visuals of a child in the french
film cuties according to a statement
from tyler county's district attorney
the document filed on september 23 said
netflix promoted material in the film
that depicts lewd exhibition of the
public
of the rather of the pubic area of a
clothed or partially clothed child
who was uh younger than 18 years of age
which appeals to the
prurient interests in sex
netflix said in a statement that cuties
is a social commentary against the
sexualization of young children
discharges without merit and we stand by
the film
so this is a government enforcing basic
standards of decency
i'm all for it i love it i think it's a
great thing i'm glad the government's
doing
it i wish more uh local governments
would do this
but i do think it's in and this is this
has been the reaction i've noticed from
i haven't seen any conservative
objectivists this this most
conservatives anyway are celebrating
this and saying good um
the interesting thing though is i i can
remember
about a year ago when we were talking
about laws related to pornography
some of us were making the case that the
government should enforce basic
standards of decency especially to
protect children
and a whole lot of conservatives had a
big problem with that
if if there's been a change in heart
that's great maybe we're starting to
realize that yeah protecting children
that sort of thing that the government
does have a role there
all right number four um big news here
if i can find it
oh here's the big news
apple is turning the mask emoji frown
upside down in an upcoming update to the
ios this according to cnn
the mask emoji has typically been used
to represent someone who is in the
medical field or is sick
however with mass becoming more
ubiquitous due to the pandemic
apple is changing the emojis look in the
upcoming why am i even reading this
anyway they've got more mask emojis
coming okay that's all
i only bring this up just just because
it's further proof i think of my point
that emojis are stupid that's all
there you go evidence number five
finally oklahoma county jail employee
employees
gregory cornell butler jr and christian
charles miles have been charged with
cruel cruelty and conspiracy
for handcuffing inmates and forcing them
to listen to baby shark
on repeat for hours
now as a parent i'm
thrilled to find out that i can actually
have my children prosecuted for
committing similar crimes against me
i think many parents have have dealt
with this no granted my kids never
really got into the baby shark craze
thank god for me it's been the book
um we're going on a bear hunt that is
our baby shark
that is the thing that is that is heard
that it reverberates through our
household at all hours of the day
all of my kids have been obsessed with
this with this book they like to have
the book read to them
they like to watch videos of other
people reading the book
they like to listen to musical
renditions of her going on a bear hunt
it is it is torturous it has
ruined my life
we're going on a bear hunt we're gonna
catch a big one
what a beautiful day we're not scared
uh-oh grass long wavy grass we can't go
over it we can't go under it got to go
through it swishy swashy swishy swashy
and on and on and on that's how the book
goes repeating itself
for pages and pages and the book doesn't
even make sense first of all
the onomatopeias that it uses are
completely arbitrary
swishy swashy for grass what kind of
grass is swishy swashy
and the plot is even worse the plot is
this family
mom dad kids young kids walking through
the woods
trying to catch a bear what what sort of
neglectful psychotic parent
brings their kids into the woods to
catch a bear a big bear it's even
specified
this this but this is this this book is
basically an account
of an attempted murder-suicide that's
how that's how
disturbing it is it might as well be
we're gonna go
drown ourselves yay it really is that
and you know it's brainwashed my kids on
top of it
every time we're in the woods now we go
for a hike or something every time my
son
is is saying let's go on a bear hunt and
i say oh
you're going to hunt for a bear huh with
what we don't even have a hunting rifle
what are you going to use a stick
the kid's going to get himself mulled
and you know what it's going to be the
fault of this book
so we all have every parent has
something like that that tortures them
it's different for all of us um
okay hopefully one day our kids will be
brought to justice for inflicting this
psychological torch around us
we're getting into our daily
cancellation now now today for our daily
cancellation i'm afraid i must play
some deeply unsettling footage for you i
wish there was another way i wish i
didn't have to subject you to this but
i'm afraid a mere description will not
suffice
so here it is i'm naked
i'm completely butt ass naked i'm naked
i'm like naked there isn't a man behind
me these are my hands
why you want me to be naked i know what
you're thinking you're thinking ruffalo
um
put your clothes on to be honest i wish
i could
cover my hands with my boobs but here we
are i'm here to talk to you about voting
did you know
that ballads could be naked and if you
don't do exactly what i tell you your
ballot could get
thrown out this is uh my ballot just got
it
first of all when your ballot comes
you're supposed to read the instructions
read and follow the instructions that
come
with your ballot if they say to use the
black pen use a black pen
i know that's like literally the least
sexy thing a completely naked person
could say but
but i have cram like can of pepsi this
problem
number two in some states like
pennsylvania
pennsylvania pennsylvania there are two
envelopes you have to
stuff your ballot in otherwise it's
called a naked ballot
naked and you don't want to have one of
those
number three mail your ballot in
as soon as you can don't sit on them
get those things out asap like
now do it get it in as soon as you can
i gotta get my ballot to the
[ __ ] post office let's go
please vote take your clothes off and
vote
vote vote vote everyone's voice matters
in this election
please vote america needs you
[Music]
yes the celebrities are at it again i'm
afraid this time naked
and the makers of this particular
montage did not appear to be selecting
participants based on their physical
attractiveness
it seems they were selected based simply
on their level of personal desperation
and shamelessness
now it is somewhat amazing that
celebrities keep coming out with these
psas particularly this format the
montage of various celebrities saying
different words they keep doing this
even though they are roundly mocked and
derided every time
even more perplexing the same
celebrities are often involved mark
ruffalo's
psa resume is more extensive than his
filmography
at this point it's also more widely
viewed i think
they just they can't get enough of it
this guy in particular
mark ruffalo and he appears to think we
can't get enough of him
but we can and we have in fact i'm not
sure that anyone on earth has
at any point ever said to themselves i'm
not sure what to make of this particular
issue
i hope mark ruffalo releases a psa but
if such a person does exist
they must be in a near constant state of
euphoria because the psas
never stop but i want to be clear about
something that
i am not just canceling these
celebrities for this psa and i'm not
just canceling celebrity psas in general
though i am canceling both
my real problem here is that this is a
get out the vote
psa which is my least favorite type
i am i'm canceling all get out the vote
efforts get out the vote videos psas
billboards campaigns whatever
they're all canceled i hate all of them
none of them should exist
and the reason is very simple if you
need if you need
naked celebrities or anyone else to tell
you to vote
and encourage you and even explain how
to do it how to fill in a mail-in ballot
or press a button
then you are exactly the sort of person
who should not be voting
all of the people who should be voting
are the ones who do not need to be told
or reminded to do it
much less do they need the process
explained to them
that's because they are informed
competent mature adults
this is the precise category of person
that we want at the polls
we don't want anyone else any effort to
get anyone
but informed and competent people to the
polls is bad and should be abolished and
banned and criminalized
this all goes back to the familiar but
still rather new
american attitude that sees voting as a
sacred duty of all americans that you
know thinks that
anyone who votes should be proud of
themselves they should put on an
i voted sticker and take a selfie and
post it on instagram and say
look world i voted aren't you proud of
me
no i'm not and you shouldn't be proud of
yourself if you voted just to vote if
you voted just simply because it's your
right or your alleged responsibility
no it's not your responsibility to
simply vote it is your responsibility
to make an informed knowledgeable
well-reasoned vote
that is the only good kind of vote all
other kinds of votes are bad and harmful
and helping to destroy our republic so
if you are not informed and not
knowledgeable
then the best thing you can do for your
country the most patriotic thing
the most responsible thing is not to
vote
if you vote despite being uninformed
then you should be ashamed
not proud of having inflicted your
stupidity on the country
so enough of the get out the vote drives
let the people
who know what's going on who keep
themselves informed
who have done the leg work prior to
voting vote
let everybody else remain in their
doritos stained
netflix stupor we don't need them on
election day
we don't want them do your duty
if you're in that category and stay home
no matter what the naked celebrities
tell you
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
mike pence wrecks kamala harris liberal
celebrities strip for democracy and
president trump works the art of the
deal on
china virus relief check it out on the
michael knowles show